- Wednesday.
Patience baby!
You don't build the
biggest building in town
by trying to rush into things.
I'm just watching so
many people make so many
short-term decisions 'cause of patience.
Patience is absolutely the
foundation for so many people.
And happiness and
relationships and business.
If there's anything that
I could wish on people,
it's for them to understand
that you have more time
at a macro, and you need
to go faster in the micro.
Day in and day out faster,
year in, year out, slower.
(slow piano music)
Andy and I are adding people
to Team Gary Vee around running
some of these Instagram
media accounts that we own.
And so, content creation and growth.
Swipe up to apply.
- So the book, I'd love some advice.
- [Gary] When's it coming out?
- So, you'll tell me
whether this is a good idea.
- You know what I admire about you?
You really, really know
how to hold your breath.
- [Scott] What do you mean by that?
- I think the thing
that really makes me me,
when I talk to myself about
myself to myself, that makes
me the most happy, is I am
able to be a good person
'cause I'm good at holding my breath.
When you're talented, you can give.
- So, 19 minute video, so
everybody said no one's
gonna watch a 19 minute video.
- [Gary] Everybody watches 19 minute--
- So a lot of people watched it.
I was in Uganda two months
ago, and I got an email
that a 93-year-old man
in a retirement community
in Austin watched the video
and he called the office
and gave half a million dollars.
We want the story to be out there.
- [Gary] That's exactly
what's gonna happen.
- You never know who it
moves, you never know.
It's like seeds.
- My friend, there's a big
difference between building
a brand and selling.
- Well, I'm just telling the story.
Right?
- [Gary] You're building a brand.
Like, you know, of course
you're selling on a micro,
you're branding on a macro.
That's what I do.
I have an idea.
- [Scott] All right.
- And I think this is fuckin' brilliant.
And I think you can pull it off.
My man, I think you can pull it off.
Look, the thing that you've
done remarkably well is brand.
There's something here.
- Our hack event starts tomorrow, so--
- This is real.
- It's an interesting idea.
- I knew you'd love it.
I'm pumped!
- Thanks, dude.
(knuckles rapping)
- If this actually
happens, I want it to be
in the museum one day.
- Um.
This may actually surprise you.
- How are you, my man?
- Fine.
- 1% battery life.
- 1%.
- Did you shit when I just emailed you?
- I shit.
No, I didn't even read
it, to be honest with you,
I was with my team.
- Thank god, thank god.
'Cause I thought it was a
phone call, and I was like
fuck, we missed it, we'll
have to reschedule it.
And then Tyler comes and
goes, "Dude, the guy's here."
I'm like, "Oh, thank god."
- I told him last time, I woulda came.
Listen, I got some cannolis from Brooklyn.
- I love it, actually, you know what?
I'm not supposed to eat
this shit, but cannolis
from Brooklyn I'm supposed to.
- I didn't know if it was
a cheat day, but I want--
- No, no, no.
I'm gonna make it one.
Cannolis are like, sorry Jordan.
- So listen, these are the special things.
These are called empanollis.
It's like, imagine an
empanada crust with some sugar
and the best kinda like ricotta cheese.
It's an Italian thing.
- Oh, I know what this thing is.
This fuckin' thing is the best.
- [Chris] The best bakery in Brooklyn.
And I gotcha some stuff.
- Thank you, brother.
- [Chris] You're welcome.
Yeah, it's the shit.
- Yeah.
- [Chris] That's the
fuckin' shit right there.
- It's so good.
Oh, my god!
Hey!
(shouting)
- [Chris] Party foul!
- Who wants to die?
- [Woman] What is that?
- Share this.
- [Woman] It looks good.
- Does anybody wanna die out of happiness?
This is so fucking good--
- [Woman] Canollis in there.
(laughing)
What is it?
- I have to bite it again.
- [Woman] Does it have cream in it?
(mumbling)
- Thanks, thank you.
(rustling)
(mumbling)
- That always happens with the cream shit.
Good job, Ty.
- [Ty] Geez, that was fuckin' good.
(speakers drowning each other out)
- Can you take this, I'm good.
Cool.
How are you, my friend?
- [Chris] Thank you, so much
for seeing me, that was--
- Of course, man, you won!
- [Chris] I feel bad about that.
- 60 Second Club.
Why do you feel bad?
All right, take these out to everybody.
1% battery life--
- [Chris] You're busy,
you know what I mean?
- No worries.
- [Chris] So, yeah,
listen, I want to just,
to be honest with you--
- Yeah, tell me about yourself.
- I've been the type of
person my whole life that
I never realized that I have
entrepreneurial tendencies,
and I've done things my
entire life that are really--
- Are you the dude that was on a TV show?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I remember now.
- I did a few TV shows, I went to college,
you know what I'm saying?
My parents, my father's a
fire fighter, they always
kinda raised me like Brooklyn--
- [Gary] Yeah, I know it, I know it.
- Go to college, gotta go get
a city job, get a union job.
- [Gary] Yep, mm-hmm.
- That wasn't who I was, but
I listened like a knucklehead.
- [Gary] No, like everybody does.
I get it.
- So, I'm in high school going--
- [Gary] How old are you now?
- I'm 28.
- [Gary] Love it, so much time.
- But when I was in
high school, I used to,
I was on My Super Sweet 16
when I was 16 years old.
I used to be a dancer and
an MC for VJ companies.
I was always in the spotlight,
I started my own business
back then, but I never
looked at it as being
a business man, I was
trying to make some money.
- [Gary] Yeah, of course.
- So, I used to sell white
Uptowns, and $5.00 reports
in high school.
I always had these--
- [Gary] You were hustling.
- Sales skills, but I never
thought of myself as that.
So, I knew I wanted to be something big.
Graduated college.
Gotta be honest with you.
I applied for the Jersey
Shore before it came out.
I was finalist.
Vinny won over me.
So, after that I was--
- That's devastating.
(laughing)
- And we didn't know what the show was.
I didn't know what the show was--
- When that show exploded,
you were like fuck me.
- (mumbling) I'm going to
make it somehow, someway.
- [Gary] 'Cause you were so pissed, right?
- I was like fuck.
So, I sign up on all these
shows, and I got on a show.
It was called The Choice.
It was to see if a regular guy
from the streets could make
a celebrity fall for them.
So, I went onstage in front
of 1,000 people in CBS Studios
in Hollywood, I had 30
seconds to spit game.
And it was like The Voice.
- [Gary] I love it.
- Right?
So, all the chairs, it was
Miss America, it was Playmate
of the Year, it was
Sofie Monk, an actress,
and Carmen Electra.
- [Gary] I love it, I love it.
- There was fuckin' doctors
and lawyers, Marines--
- [Gary] What did you say?
- They were like say this.
I was like--
- [Gary] I'm gonna say my thing.
- I don't need help, I'm gettin' this.
- [Gary] Yeah, right.
- One thing you can't tell me about--
- [Gary] This is the
one thing I'm good at!
- This is the one thing
I'm good with (mumbling),
I was like let me do what I gotta do.
I went out there, I said four words.
I was, "Yous all gorgeous."
Ding, ding, ding.
They all picked me.
I won the show in 30 seconds.
I got Carmen Electra.
- I love it!
That's amazing.
- So, I'm just sittin'
there now, I'm like, yo,
they weren't kidding.
They were like after you
do the show, it's a high--
- [Gary] And then a low, yeah.
- So, I have a St. John's degree
for Hospitality Management
'cause when I was in college,
I was like, "I don't like
"math, I don't like science.
"I'm a people guy."
I was a salesman, I didn't know.
- [Gary] I totally understand.
- [Man] Sorry, I was gonna roll.
Do you want to say a quick word--
- [Gary] I do, give me two seconds.
- Sure.
- My man, I'm gonna throw
you in the car with me
'cause I have to go to Yankee Stadium.
Not right now.
When am I leaving?
- [Man] You can leave in 25.
- Okay.
So, let's do the call right
now, the eBay thing, cool.
- [Chris] Switch it out?
- Yeah.
And then we'll hang for like
10, 15 minute, I'll drop
you off in the Bronx.
Hello, how are you?
(slow electronic music)
I'm super smart, like super smart.
Iris.
- [Man On Phone] One way
for you to think about is--
- I'm on this kick lately,
I'm startin' to realize,
I'm really smart, right?
Like super?
(laughing)
- [Man On Phone] Dedicated
to the team and talk.
And then there's a small--
- Hi YouTube.
♫ Made it all
♫ Don't strain
♫ My cause you God all say the same thing
♫ Oh
♫ Don't strain
- The problem is I think it's
a feature, not a platform.
- It's a feature.
Right, so you think Facebook
or something like that can--
- Of course.
You are so gifted in
emotional intelligence
and people skills.
- Me?
- And you're deploying
it against a technology
and operations business.
My intuition, not best use of time.
You're makin' a mistake.
Let me tell you what
mistake you're making.
You're letting other people do it for you.
I'm doing it for myself.
- Right, of course.
- If I was as good looking
as you, I'd have 11 million
fucking followers.
You're not listening.
- No, do it myself.
- You're not listening.
- I hear you.
No, you're right.
Do it myself.
- I know I'm right.
- I know, that's why--
- You're deploying your
energy against something
that has no shot of
winning, in my opinion.
None.
And I know like the truck,
and like, it's not fun
for me to say that.
By the way, I could be wrong.
I've been wrong before.
Let's keep everything,
I'm not a fuckin' genie.
- Of course.
- But, my intuition is
we are now in the era
where guys like you don't
have to be at the mercy
of MTV, it's the golden era of that.
- I can do it myself.
- And you're doing two things wrong.
First, you're deploying
your magic against something
that you shouldn't, and then number two,
in the place where you have
the magic, you're trying
to let somebody else control your outcome.
Because what you have is
not something can be bought.
- Bought.
- What you need to do
is you need to bring all
that energy, and you need to do this.
You should become a reality
TV star on Facebook,
Instagram, Snapchat and YouTube.
You should vlog.
Your life.
Your dating life, your homie's life,
your basketball life, your
fuckin' buying new sneakers life.
You personally will make
over a million dollars
a year being you.
♫ Ain't that what they always say
♫ Wait
♫ They don't love you like I love you
♫ Oh, they don't love you like I love you
♫ That's right
♫ They don't love you like I love you
- I'm doing the best thing ever.
I have so many sneakers here,
that I'm wearing sneakers
from my closet that I don't
want anymore, that I give
away to random people, and
then I put on the new ones.
Amazing.
- [Man] I don't have anything
locked in, right now.
- What are they 10 1/2?
Anybody want boots?
- [Colin] I'm takin' 'em.
- 10 1/2, all right, 10 1/2 Colin?
- [Colin] Yeah.
- 10 1/2?
(chattering)
Everybody's a 10 1/2!
Oh, you know, dude?
Are you outta your mind?
I'm not supposed to do any
Red Eyes, now you want me
to do Red Eye connectors?
We've digressed.
(slow electronic music)
- [Don] Gary!
Finally.
- Real pleasure.
- You talk a lot about hustle,
you talk a lot about drive.
The number one thing
that we see a lot of is
that a lot of students don't
know what to hustle on.
They're swiping on their
phones, their attention is
somewhere else, and there
seems to be this misnomer
that as long as I get a
really good SAT score,
I'll go to that college of
my choice, and then once
I go to the college of my
choice, everything will be okay.
- Yeah.
It's a misnomer.
Misnomers and stereotypes and
things like that are grounded
in truths; there was a
time and day and age.
There was no conversation when
we went through K through 12
where there was any outlet
other than the variable
of your success was gonna be
predicated on what college
you went to.
I was making real money.
Like real money.
I was making 1,000,
2,000, $3,000 a weekend
as a 12, 13, 14, 15 year
old, and there was nobody
in my life, outside of my
parents, who deemed that
as a proxy or a preview to success.
That is insane.
- So, let's just say that if we're all
just virtually watching
your blogs, and that's just
a part of class, once
again, the hard part is
the collaboration and the work.
So, I don't necessarily
think that we're all going
to stay at home and watch video tutorials.
I don't think that's powerful.
I think getting together is powerful.
However, if Gary were to
transform a, let's just go
with middle school or high
school, what is the first
thing you start with?
- Well, I think, the first
thing I start with is,
it's funny how many different
places my brain went.
One of the places my brain
went is first I gotta get
people to send their kids there.
So, it's about the marketing
of what the fuck I'm up to.
Right?
But if you're saying that's
all done, and you're talking
more about the curriculum
or the execution or what are
we actually doing there,
the first thing we do is
we memorize zero
information ever, forever.
It's rule number one of the bill of rights
of my school.
Zero, zero memorization of information.
Information's commoditized.
It's at the fingertips
of every single person.
Memorizing or knowing any
information is dick shit.
It's out.
It's outlawed.
It is not valued.
And we do not score on it.
I think the first thing, I'd
build an entrepreneur school,
and so the first class
and the first day is
all about selling.
I believe selling is the
seed, in a lot of ways,
of entrepreneurship.
I feel like not everybody's
a, so I sell, but I sell
by building brand and
letting people come to me.
- Right.
- I hate asking somebody to buy something.
I don't like the feeling
of not having the leverage.
So, I think the first
thing would be teaching
a selling class.
So, probably the first day
of school, given my narrative
in my career, would be Lemonade
101, and everybody would
kinda walk in, and depending
on if it was a middle school,
I would still call it Lemonade,
but what we'd probably do
is we would buy and sell something.
Most likely, we go, so,
my curriculum would change
every year, my concepts
would change every year,
but it would be a 100%
doing organization, right?
We would teach something on
Monday, and we would do it,
literally, Tuesday, Wednesday,
Thursday and Friday.
And then some version of that.
I don't know if that goes
another week, or if every Monday,
I'm willing to teach something.
But four out of five days is
doing, and so day number one,
today, if it started
tomorrow, is retail arbitrage.
I believe every single person
listening to this can make
$100,000 a year, $100,000
a year, and have very good
work, life balance, by
buying stuff in one place,
and selling it on the
Internet somewhere else.
- [Don] One piece of
advise to that 17 year old,
who is really thinking
either about a gap year,
college, or not.
- So, as far as the 17 year
old, look, I think one thing
you should know is you have a
very long life ahead of you.
It's crazy to me how
the human brain works.
You never have patience.
At 17, you feel like,
anybody who's 41 to 45 knows
that how they felt at 17, you
felt, I mean, when we were 21,
a 41 year old was almost dead.
The oldest shit of all time.
And now, we feel like we're 21, still.
In our brains.
We don't look it, in the
wrinkle, we got the wrinkles now.
So, I think the biggest thing
I would tell a 17 year old is
you have so much time,
it's actually laughable.
So, make a decision, whether
gap year of college or not,
completely predicated
on realizing that your
life is so long, you have so much time.
You can probably make nothing
but mistakes for the next
13 years of your life,
and probably still have
a tremendously happy life,
and once you wrap your head
around that, it probably
empowers you to make the best
decision for yourself.
(knuckles rapping)
- [Don] 'Preciate you
being a new age teacher.
- Thank you, brother.
- Show an example.
- Thank you.
(slow electronic music)
Thank you, so much.
Love you.
See ya.
Take care.
It's 10:01 p.m., I'm
going to a dinner meeting.
Iris wanted me to say
something before I went
to my dinner meeting.
There you go, Iris.
- [Iris] Thank you.